we have so much information it will take
the full hour that we will give you
tonight that I promise you the medium
mob the single most repugnant corrupt
lying group of people in this country
with a political agenda for one party
we're gonna lay out the truth each and
every detail but the president did
absolutely nothing wrong nothing the
Democrats the media they are just
outright lying to you again three years
of Lies cover-ups conspiracy theories
and a hoax they're doing it all over
again and this is for the country I will
tell you this if you love our country
and I know you do and this is an
all-hands-on-deck moment this is about
our way of life this is about our system
of governance that has been the single
greatest system ever created by mankind
that has raised the standard of living
in the entire world life liberty pursuit
of happiness if you believe in that the
rule of law freedom our Constitution our
rights you really need to engage now
like you never have been because they on
the other side along with their cohorts
is unholy alliance the media mob the
Democratic Party that one in the same
because what they're doing is so
dangerous wanting to undo an election
under any circumstances that if they
succeed the America that we inherited
will be unrecognizable as we speak what
is happening they are attempting to
remove a duly elected president from
office based on nothing but a
manufactured crisis now a second
witch-hunt after three years of the
first witch on four investigations no
collusion well they now started at
another one but this time they're not
gonna make the same mistake which is oh
we're not gonna wait three years and
then get disappointed in the end when it
doesn't come out the way we thought it
was going to come out this is devoid of
actual crimes misdemeanors even minor
impropriety doesn't exist here and the
great irony is that once again it is the
Democrats that are guilty of nearly
every single accusation they are
throwing at the president you elected
that they want to remove from office
it's now running theme on the left and
the media everything they accused the
president of they themselves are guilty
of doing you want a clear evidence of a
quid pro quo okay look no further than
sleepy creepy crazy Uncle Joe he's
bragging about it now what about Russia
collusion okay we had Hillary Clinton
yeah the dirty Russian dossier with
funneled money hiring a an OP Research
Group and mi6 Christopher steel there
has the New York Times called it Russian
disinformation from the get-go and then
it was used of course to spy on the
Trump campaign transition and even a
President of the United States one of
numerous ways this president has had to
deal with things that no other president
has ever had to deal with before
now it's Ukrainian collusion in 2016 a
DNC now pay attention this a DNC
contractor was paid hundreds of
thousands of dollars why to pressure
Ukraine and Ukrainian officials to dig
up dirt on Donald Trump and trash his
campaign and as an added bonus oh we do
have four US senators that's right let's
see Menendez Murphy Leahy oh and dick
Durbin they're all our records
threatening the government of Ukraine
with untold consequences if they don't
comply with their anti Trump demands and
their investigation witch-hunt from the
Russia issue where's all the hysteria
over those quid pro quos only matters if
they can bludgeon Trump you know for
example Hillary she yeah paid for
Russian lies to influence the campaign
nobody said a thing after she stole a
primary rigged it after she had a rigged
investigation that kept her in the race
and she gets the insurance policy Wow
what about the hysteria over all those
examples of collusion only if it's
trouble only you know where are the I
believer is surrounding a Democratic
lieutenant governor and in Virginia you
know what we're watching here as a
pattern unfolding and it's it's it's
sort of a quickening now and that is
they're not gonna wait three years well
we'll just impeach them a B let's pick
it out of a hat
and the mob of course supports it with
no logic no facts no reason you have to
suspend every bit of god-given
intelligence and common sense you have
to believe there's anything to this and
we'll have all the details about the
hypocrisy coming up tonight now we do
have Joe Biden's campaign well they want
to actually stop Rudy Giuliani from
talking demanding TV executives block
him from appearing on shows like ours by
the way they don't want him exposing the
truth about yeah what joe did with the
prosecutor why would a Vice President of
the United States of America want a
Ukrainian prosecutor fired or he's gonna
withhold six billion dollars and by the
way you only have six hours to do it
that would be a shakedown by Biden Oh
for the reason of oh that's right he
wants to protect his son who had no
experience in Ukraine oil gas or energy
and was getting paid a fortune millions
of dollars and Giuliani by the way was
also just subpoenaed by House Democrats
this is going to be one of the greatest
shows on earth can't wait to see that
Rudy Giuliani will join us in a moment
and if Biden would like to defend his
actions as vice president we've invited
him on the show up I'll give him a whole
week's worth of shows hiya show and
cable he can join us right here five
nights in a row so Joe 303 303 hours of
my radio show a lot more on that but
first we do have major breaking news
that is devastating to our national
security
once again the contents of yet another
private phone call between our president
and a world leader was leaked this time
to the New York Times this is now the
fourth time the fourth example leaking
the president's confidential
communications with world leaders let's
see Australia then Mexico to Ukraine and
now Australia again a raw dough put it
well this president has been forced to
deal with quote snitches and rats and
backstabbers for three years people
within our government trying to sabotage
undermine and undo an election what
other president has ever had to deal
with this think about it
each day President Trump now has to work
against powerful unelected deep state
bureaucrats that hate him
how does he get to do his job at what
point does this become dangerous for the
entire world if he can't negotiate in
good faith with world leaders what world
leader will ever talk to the president
and confidence on a phone call and some
of these bad actors are now spying on
the president's communications and
leaking them to the media it is a
massive national security crisis who is
spying and leaking this information
calls between world leaders must be some
of the most guarded conversations in the
White House
world leaders must be able to
communicate freely and clearly with our
president that would be good for world
peace negotiations our economy but
that's never going to happen again the
trust is now forever been broken the
world is less safe because of what these
people are doing abusing the powerful
tools of intelligence that we entrust to
them to keep us safe not to use his
political weaponry against American
citizens or an American president and so
far we've seen leaks as I said Mexico
Australia Ukraine and yeah now we have
another leak with the Australian Prime
Minister now if this is how business is
going to be conducted it's probably time
we get the contents of some other
people's calls other presidents for
example how about Obama's common
conversations I'll have more flexibility
after the election I'd love to hear the
after the election calls and the promise
that he made to Vladimir Putin or how
about the full transcript of Obama's
calls with the mullahs in Iran or
President rouhani that led up to this
horrible nuclear deal and him given 150
billion dollars to yes the the number
one state sponsor a terror that wants to
wipe Israel and the u.s. off the map
and while we're at it why don't we get
Biden's Communications and phone calls
and transcripts of the leaders of
Ukraine that he talked to when he was
put in charge of Ukraine and that's when
his son got his lucrative deal is that
what they want and by the way what was
the big so called bombshell development
from the most recent leak all right look
at the New York Times president Trump
requested the Australian government that
they cooperate with
the Attorney General's investigation
into what is the origins of the Russia
probe in other words a DOJ official is
now telling Fox News the Attorney
General did ask the President to make
standard introductions to officials in
multiple countries who may have
pertinent information in the ongoing
barred Orem probe according to the
Department of Justice these requests are
not out of the ordinary at all and so
far the countries have been very helpful
without any need for pressure from the
White House and you won't likely hear
this from the media mob you see this is
the part of the story in the rush of
witch-hunt that they didn't want to pay
attention to yes we're going to get the
story on fives abuse and the inspector
general's report we're also going to get
the bar dirham report at some point -
and the investigations into the origins
of this Russia witch-hunt incredibly
important non partisan investigation a
big piece of the probe surrounds whether
or not let's see
Obama administration Intel people at the
highest levels whether they tried to
circumvent United States law spying on
American citizens by simply
circumventing the law and outsourcing
and subcontracting the illegal
surveillance to Intel agencies and
foreign countries like Great Britain can
you do me a favor I need information on
Oh president Trump Italy do you mind
spying on a president Australia yeah all
of those countries are being looked into
as having done that for yes our own
intelligence people because legally they
can't so they thought they were being
cute trying to get around that law so
it's pretty clear why the Department of
Justice would be to be working with
Australian Italian and authorities in
Great Britain the probe into the origins
of the Russia witch hunt is a very real
investigation into real serious
government abuse of power and corruption
Democrats the media they've never told
you that story they don't care about
actual crimes that they did they would
have clearly seen what we did a slam
dunk case Hillary Clinton committed
multiple felonies on the Espionage Act
they would have seen she obstructed
justice when she deleted the subpoenaed
emails and all the other garbage
they would see that when says at the top
of a FISA application verified and you
don't verify it and use Russian lies to
spy on spy on a campaign and then a
transition team and then a presidency
and deny and other American their
constitutional rights yeah they would
have told you that story too but they
well conveniently left it out instead
the left is totally consumed with hatred
for all things Donald Trump in fact they
have spent only the last three years
trying to find some way any way to
impeach him look at News Buster's the
mob began calling for impeachment only
two days two days after he got elected
for the next 35 consecutive months guess
what
more and more calls for impeachment
never ending impeachment impeachment
impeachment what it does to the country
they don't care they care about peace
and protecting our country they don't
care about that either they care about
economic opportunity and jobs and the
and the economy they don't seem to take
a look every day Donald Trump now sits
at the threshold of impeachment we're
introducing articles of impeachment to
remove President Trump from office given
the events of today the likelihood of
impeachment I'm not saying it's highness
airily but it certainly went out the
Constitution could not be any clearer
impeachment is the appropriate remedy
he told us enough to interpret what he
said as a referral for impeachment
proceedings it's time for us to impeach
this president we are considering what
to do about it including the possible
voting of the articles of impeachment
there should be an impeachment inquiry
opened yeah we're gonna get lectures
from her any anything missing from all
the hysteria no crimes no misdemeanors
no conspiracy no collusion no
obstruction anger conspiracy theories
outright lying repeatedly propaganda
misinformation slanders smearing
besmirching that
what you get from your modern-day
Democratic extreme Socialist Party and
God forbid they ever give you your green
New Deal and Medicare for all this is
what they wanted since 2016 now
Democrats and the mob they value
vengeance above all else you're so
disappointed that their lies didn't
become their reality and their current
impeachment Asteria surrounds nothing
but what is a non-story about a
perfectly normal telephone call between
the president and his Ukrainian
counterpart we now have the transcript
there was no quid pro quo there was no
collusion there was no misconduct the
United States and Ukraine even have a
treaty that allows the two countries
mandates that we cooperate in the
investigation yes the president was
saying we had all this trouble with our
election and you guys were at the center
of it
president by the way had this to say
about the hysteria take a look this
whole thing is a disgrace there's been
tremendous corruption and we're seeking
it
it's called drain the swamp there's been
corruption on the other side it's been
corrupted like you've never seen now the
new president of Ukraine ran on the
basis of no corruption that's how we get
elected and I believe that he really
means it but there was a lot of
corruption having to do with the 2016
election against us and we want to get
to the bottom of it and it's very
important that we do thank you did you
bring up it you got to read the
transcripts this was a perfectly normal
legal phone call so normal in fact that
no leaker liar you know can a cowardly
ship he had to make up his own
fabricated version of the transcript
oome performed a dramatic reading during
an official hearing meanwhile there are
so many unanswered questions surrounding
a whistleblower that's not a
whistleblower and the report and all of
this leaking in the dangers that it
poses to this country and our
constitutional governance why so they
can push this president out because as
one congressman said back in May yeah we
can't beat him you probably the only way
to get rid of as a Peacham and that is
you know all of these question